♪♪♪
>> HIP HOP HAS ALWAYS BEEN
EXTREMELY COMPETITIVE,
ESPECIALLY BETWEEN THE
GENERATIONS.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU ALWAYS GOTTA
PAY HOMAGE TO THE PIONEERS THAT
PUT IT DOWN BEFORE US BECAUSE IF
IT WASN'T FOR THEM, WE WOULDN'T
BE HERE.
IT IS A RESPECT THING.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A STUDENT OF
HIP HOP.
YOU SEE RAPPERS COMING OUT
GETTING DEALS WITHOUT EVEN
KNOWING THE HISTORY OF THE GAME.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> PERHAPS THERE IS NO BETTER
EXAMPLE THAN THIS BUDDING
SOUNDCLOUD RAPPER, LIL' DOO DOO.
♪ DOODIE GANG
DOODIE GANG
DOODIE GANG ♪
♪ WIPE MY BUTT
WITH COCAINE ♪
>> HE CAUSED CONTROVERSY
RECENTLY WHEN HE CLAIMED
PUBLICLY THAT HE'S NEVER HEARD
RAP BEFORE 2009.
>>>.
>> MY INFLUENCES?
SOMETIMES I LISTEN TO OLD
SCHOOL HIP HOP LIKE SOULJA BOY,
BOW WOW, NICK CANNON, YOU FEEL
ME?
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT, RUN
DMC?
>> I THINK HILLARY CLINTON
SHOULD HAVE WON.
>> HIS DUDE RUBBED MANY HIP HOP
PIONEERS THE WRONG WAY, MOST
NOTELY, THE SOLE CRASH CREW.
>> MAN, ALL THAT INK ON HIS FACE
MUST BE SEEPING INTO HIS BRAIN.
KIDS IN THE OLD SCHOOL IN THE
SOUL CRUSH CREW.
I DON'T EVEN RECOGNIZE THE NEW
JUNK.
HE WOULD NOT HAVE MADE IT BACK
IN MY DAY, WHERE IT ALL STARTED.
♪♪♪
>> LET ME TAKE YOU BACK.
1978, THE BRONX, NEW YORK.
BROKEN GLASS.
RATS AND ROACHES.
ABANDONED BUILDINGS.
WE HAD TO DRESS TOUGH NOT LIKE
THESE CLOWNS HERE.
>> I'M COOL KENNY BLADE.
>> CHIEF.
>> AND I'M DJ GRAND WHIZ AR
KARATE.
>> AND TOGETHER WE ARE THE SOUL
CRUSH CREW.
ROUGH!
>> WHAT THE [ BLEEP ] IS THAT,
BRA?
>> WE LOOK GOOD.
ALL LEATHER EVERYTHING.
CHAINS.
SPIKES.
FINGERLESS GLOVES.
AND ABSOLUTELY NO UNDERCLOTHES.
>> FUR COAT.
PEARLS.
BROACHES, PILLBOX HATS.
TOUGH STUFF.
>> SEE, WE WAS A GROUP.
SO WE HAD TO MATCH.
MY THING WAS INDIAN HEAD DRESSES
AND CHAPS
BECAUSE I'M CHIEF BRONCO.
>> I ALWAYS WORE KARATE PANTS
BECAUSE MY BEAT WAS KICKING.
>> AND I NEVER WORE DRAWERS.
SWINGING.
>> YOU HEARD OF SOUL CRUSH CREW?
>> SOUL CRUSH CREW?
UH.
>> SINGING ABOUT POPPING PILLS
AND SIPPING LEAN.
PLEASE, THESE DRUGS ARE FRYING
YOUR BRAIN.
THE ONLY DRUGS WE EVER DID WAS
REEFER WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
CRACK IN IT.
>> DON'T EVEN HAVE A DJ.
>> ALL OUR RAPS WAS CLEAR AND
CONCISE.
AND EVERYTHING MADE SENSE.
♪♪♪
DIBBY DIBBY, DABBA DABBA DIBBY.
DIBBY DIBBY DABBY DIBBY.
DABBA DIBBY DIBBAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THEY'RE THE ONLY RAPPERS THAT
I KNOW THAT ARE PRO CRACK.
♪ TO THE BEAT, Y'ALL
YOU DON'T STOP
I LIKE MY REEFER
WITH CRACK ROCK ♪
RUFF!
>> ALL RIGHT TURN THAT OFF.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
>> WHAT?
BOY, YOU ARE RIDICULOUS.
YOUR RAPS ARE RIDICULOUS.
>> LOOK AT THIS CHUMP.
I BET YOU DON'T EVEN GOT A DJ.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, HOLD
ON HOLD ON LET'S TAKE FIVE,
EVERYONE.
>> I TALKED TO THESE DUDES,
GUYS, WE COOL NOW.
YOU FEEL ME.
WE SMOKED SOME WEED.
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF CRACK IN
IT.
RUFF!